[Musique]
on reste à versailles pour quelque chose
de plus positif avec mélanie poker
bonsoir
alors pour ce rendez-vous loisirs dont
vous nous donnez parler chaque semaine
on se range e ledy à versailles le
tournoi d'asma team est de retour dans
la cité royale
et oui pour cette troisième édition les
organisateurs ont vu plus grand depuis
deux ans le rendez-vous tourner autour
d'un seul jeu alors stone pour attirer
un public un peu plus grand public et
faire se rencontrer plus de joueurs il y
a deux nouveaux tournois qui sont
proposés par ahmat hymne au tour de
league of legends et le deuxième c'est
pour les fans de football c'est fifa va
écouter le fait qu'ils aient plus de
choix permet aux de rassembler et puis
au niveau de pas connu de versailles
c'est un petit peu la même idée c'est
qu'il avait eu des retours comme quoi il
y avait des gens qui trouvent une
initiative très bonne mais comme ce
n'est pas sur le jeu au pied qui jouait
pas il se trouait sans voix dit j'avais
l'impression d'un peu moins participent
à la fête le jeu qu'on a fait les deux
premières années toujours la personne
parce que c'est vrai qu'on a réussi à
créer un rendez vous donc l'idée ce
n'est pas de tout perdre
mais voilà avec les nouveaux jeux
d'ouvrir de nouvelles personnes le
tournoi débute à 13h mais pas
d'inscription à prévoir mélanie c'est
surtout de la détermination qu'il va
falloir montrer ce cas armati mais
l'amérique versailles ont choisi que
de faire que les tournois ça soit
gratuit alors elles sont pas extensibles
ses places pour être sûr de concourir il
faut arriver dès midi à l'hôtel de ville
pour s'inscrire il ya 104 places pour
league of legends 64 pour fifa et 32
pour les stones alors autre
particularité cette année il n'y a pas
de tournoi différent entre les amateurs
et les professionnels
on peut donc se tester et demander des
conseils aux meilleurs joueurs présents
alors grégory je sais de source sûre que
vous êtes un fan de fifa est ce que je
demande à ce qu'on veut garder une place
imbach j'aimerais bien mais pourquoi pas
me tester avec quelques amateurs et
quelques initiés à fifa merci mélanie
d'autres idées de sorties à retrouver
bien sûr dans votre émission le 7-8
loisirs et c'est après ce journal